hallo mein name ist luca und ihr solltet
mir fragen unter dem hashtag praktikum
auf twitter stellen und da mal antworte
ich dir jetzt wie sie bisher eine banane
hypo stecken wisst ihr wenn andere
youtuber sowas machen wieso frage und
antwort videos dann kommen so fragen wie
ja was ist denn deine einstellung zum
leben was sind deine hobbys möchtest du
später mal kinder haben wenn ich dann
mal alle sechs monate fragen beantworte
kommt dann so was wie ben bernanke
stecken das ist auch gar nicht witzig
die nächste frage lautet willst du mir
okay ich hab ich habe dann nach der
ersten frage geht es nicht schlimmer
aber du hast mich wirklich vom gegenteil
überzeugt die nächste frage kommt von
einem youtuber wo ich denke dass die
frage tatsächlich sehr sinnvoll sein
kann
das kann doch nicht wahr sein als ob
nicht eine vernünftige frage drankommt
du dummkopf
was wird ein verrücktestes zuschauer
erlebnis also was du mit einem zuschauer
ist mein verrücktes für ein erlebnis hat
mich in hamburg meine ich das ist aber
auch schon für zwei jahre her dass jetzt
noch perfekt zusammenpassen kann jetzt
aber es war auf jeden fall direkt eine
europa passage zwischen europa passage
und apple store
ich glaube die hamburger wissen wohl
dass es sicher und kam dann auf jeden
fall ein zuschauer zu mir an und war so
voll am zittern und hat mit also sein
handy gegeben meinte soja kannst und
foto machen nicht zu nehmen lieber das
was noch cooler und sondern hat er
wirklich ein handy genommen wollten foto
machen und dabei etwas heruntergefallen
und hatte in split screen danach das
krasse ist übrigens ich war an karneval
in köln
da habe ich auch so ein tolles bild bei
instagram hochgeladen wo ich geführte
bombe wurde jedenfalls ist mir dann mein
handy runtergefallen und es ist
warum apple warum warum sieht sich mein
handy wenn es einfach runter fällt das
ist doch eher das kann doch wir machen
weiter berichtet euro wirst du dir
nennen das ist keine ahnung ich weil ich
kann mir das überhaupt nicht vorstellen
so ohne komplett habe ich hatte meine
kurze zeit lang möglich die haben an den
leitungen die fünf millimeter und
obenauf von kurzen zwar nicht so geil
aber ich würde mir eigentlich recht ich
weiß ich das müsste schon in der wohl
summe sein weil mit glatze ist schon
obwohl theoretisch kann man ja den ganz
einfach cap tragen und nach 12 monaten
sind jahre dann eh wieder komplett voll
400.000 oder so hat er das bild mit dem
gefallen als sie das bild nicht kennt
das war das hier ein halte ich das
gesehen habe was sie hier rein thun
kommt zu hause wieder raus wir
verbrennen möglich zu strom und wärme
da bin ich oben in der mülltonne ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was ich zu dem
bild sagen soll außer fick dich
danke für die frage ich bin echt also
mit mit euch zu arbeiten ist wie mit
einem kaputten computer das geht einfach
nicht ich habe hier oben
was ist das ungelogen ich hab keine
ahnung dass die neues album rausgebracht
haben arbeit hörst mir jetzt mal an
möchte winter teile er die beiden hören
weil wenn wir jetzt sagst du machst dich
denn ich mag es nicht meine
klassenkameraden haben die frage kann
ich tatsächlich nicht sagen das weiß ich
nicht ob das irgendwann noch mal geben
wird
und zu meiner community kann ich sagen
also auf der einen seite seite
unglaublich
vega chillig auf der anderen seite
reicht einfach jeden scheiß den ich mit
kamera zeigen die natur ein
das ist nicht so cool mein merge kommt
am ersten zwölften in den shop die
domain wird sein luca - shop.de ja da
wird ist die frage bleibt sogar schon
beantwortet das blöde ist dass ich bei
einem shirt sonne genau perfekte
vorstellung von einem stoff hatte dieser
stoff dauert allerdings noch anderthalb
monate bis wir den irgendwie auftreiben
können italien deswegen kommen erst zwei
andere designs dafür als ersatz in den
shop und das andere shirt design kommt
dann mitte januar erst das heißt der
shop wird noch nicht direkt perfekt voll
sein aber es wird schon eine mütze geben
es wird ein beutel geben es wird einen
rudi geben für dein pullover geben und
es wird zwei mal das gleiche t shirt
einer verschiedenen farbe geben und ein
anderes t-shirt was eigentlich mein
absolutes lieblings dazu möchte ich
nichts sagen dass er geht dann am ersten
als ich noch zur schule gegangen hab ich
in freistunden mich immer mit dem
hausmeister angefeindet wir sollten ein
paar jahren die nächste frage ist du so
ein spiel
meine frage ist wenn du dir irgendwo ein
piercing stechen lassen musstest aus
welchem grund auch immer mutprobe oder
irgendwas wo würde ich müsst ihr stechen
lassen
wenn ich es machen müsste dann irgendwo
[Musik]
ich will kein 14
würdest du dir auch schlecht zu sein
die sache ist dass sich schon unmengen
an geld für meine jetzigen stofftiere
bezahlt habe deswegen na gut es ist
schon deshalb mag anna und als letzte
frage nehmen wir jetzt mal was gerade
von schreien gekommen ist was ich noch
selber noch nicht angesehen habe
geht man raus
ich bin einfach das kann doch nicht wahr
sein